[Music]
here in this video we will showcase the
differences and a comparison between the
first predator from the arnold movie of
1987 and the latest version called the
feral predator from the latest movie
called pray
so let's get to it
let's talk about the origins of the
feral predator seen in the new movie
called prey
this alien is a subspecies of the yautja
or predators as they are more commonly
known and are endemic to the southern
hemisphere of the home planet of theirs
called the outja prime it is a big alien
apex hunter with somewhat armored skin
in shades of black and brown he is seen
only wearing his wrist braces or also
known as the gauntlet
a loincloth belts for carrying his gear
and his bio helmet which can see in a
wide range of visual spectrums
his fingers are also tipped with huge
claws he also has bigger feet
long smooth dreadlocks curls on his
shoulder which are a unique mutation of
his subspecies
he also has superhuman speed like all
the others agility
strength superhuman strength as well as
a wide range of weapons that he carries
he is hinted to be the first predator to
arrive on earth thereby erasing the avp
history or timeline for good
let's talk about the body design
although seen as a big muscular and rib
predator it is still the smallest of all
the predators seen as of yet the feral
predator is around 2 meters tall which
means around 6 feet 6 inches or 6 feet 7
inches
while the original predator was taller
at over 7 feet tall and the others like
the mega one was 11 feet tall anyway it
was not also as bulky as the other ones
but had a very agile and aesthetic
physique with ripped muscles and a
hydrodynamic shoulder to waist ratio
speaking about shoulders it has quills
that grow on them and they are a result
of their unique genetics not seen in
other classic predators of species its
skin texture was way different as it had
a kind of a hard scaly armored skin akin
to lizards and wasn't a shade of brown
and black unlike the yellowish green
seen in the others it also had a reddish
coloration along the spine on its back
now what about the head and face
while there have been quite a number of
variations of the faces and skulls of
the yavja
this one brought a newer look his real
face is shown to have tiny yellow eyes
and a large white mouth with four
insect-like mandibles and fangs which
were a staple of all the others but the
differences are the proportions the
mandibles are way longer which means a
wider mouth that can give a heart
stopping roar
at the cause of the bigger mouth the
skull seems to be narrower and less
bulbous than the others even the
yellowish eyes are situated more apart
and on a higher elevation on the skull
unlike the original which seemed almost
to have a human-like proportion
the face i mean he just seems to have a
more feral look as was on purpose to
suit the name
so go into the bio helmet design
let's dissect his weapon slash computer
slash virtual assistant of his see every
predator has his own bio helmet which
can be crafted and customized to their
own liking even if many of the predators
had the classic let's say military
issued helmet which was black and
metallic in color and even darker shades
for the visors which can glow red at
certain times there are many instances
that these yautja designs
they design their own bio helmets but
the feral predator's item looked more
crude and bony in appearance and maybe
it was the skull of an alien species
that he had hunted before and then
crafted the technology within it
honestly it gives a wendigo kind of look
which was quite apt as the wenigo was
another native american monster during
that time or even now
encrypted let's say and yes his
equipment also is a cloaking device just
like all the other bio helmets in their
species arsenal
now let's look at the melee weapons the
feral predator carries a set of deadly
close combat weapons which include the
dual wrist blades which are classic to
their species
he also carries a spear which is
detachable and converts into a maze and
a shorter machete
and the best thing yet is the shield
that can open up and close into his
wrist gauntlet and can also be used to
cut things off
while the only melee weapon seen in the
original predator was the wrist blades
and the spear was only seen till the
sequel the feral predator lacked the
wire mesh that usually lines the other
predators bodies around their body which
serves some sort of purpose i guess just
wanted to point it out
and the pharaoh predator didn't have
that
now let's look at ranged weapons this
new yard carried an array of ranged
weapons as well with the spear gun being
the most deadly acid fight 3 deadly
laser guided spear tips that can
maneuver and circle around only hitting
the intended target painted by the laser
from his bio helmet although it didn't
seem to have the shoulder-based plasma
cutter like many of the rest
he also had a classic net gun which was
seen in only the second predator movie
he had several chain blades that could
snap straight before being thrown at a
target curling around and slicing the
target which are a unique set of weapons
seen only in this movie the wrist
gauntlet instead of having a mini
nuclear self-destruction option like the
one on the first film it instead had
three drone-like discs which could by
themselves track and eliminate multiple
targets by a plasma kind of explosion
so lastly let's talk about the thermal
vision while the original predator and
the feral predator both had thermal
visions as their primary senses
their unique mutations which set them
apart as sub-species also worked their
way to their eyesight
the original predator had a more blurry
yet robust field of view capable of
detecting even my new changes in
temperature fluctuations the feral
predator however had a somewhat more
sharpened eyesight on the lines of
thermal vision and are very closely
related to the original's field of view
this just like all of their species are
enhanced and visually aided by the
biohelmet's computing algorithm
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well but most
of all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos here on this
channel take care fam